the president tweeted this morning trade
wars are good and easy to win
he said when other countries quote get
cute don't trade anymore we win big it's
easy CBS News analyst Jill Schlesinger
is here with us good morning Jill to
explain all of this so tell us there are
these tariffs on steel and aluminum who
would the winners and losers be well
obviously a domestic producer of either
steel or aluminum is going to do well in
this scenario but there are some pretty
major losers that could come to bear we
could see the car industry a company
like Boeing that needs steel to make
airplanes and we could see a trickle
down even to a beer company because a
beer can is made of aluminum so there is
some clear winners and losers it may not
be necessarily passed on to the consumer
because not obviously a can of beer is
not just the aluminum some companies may
choose to actually eat that cost we'll
have to see these tariffs are gonna
cover steel and aluminum imports from
all countries around the globe how is
that going to affect the us standing
internationally what's the response
gonna be well I think this is the big
fear among economist and it's not just
what's going to happen to consumers but
will this spark a trade war and despite
what the president just tweeted in my
mind anything that says war in it not
good and so we're worried about
retaliation and specifically in a weird
way the agricultural industry is on
alert right now because many of the
retaliatory measures could be aimed at
the things that we export so that could
mean something like soybeans we are a
huge exporter of soybeans so right now
you're gonna see some industries and you
may not be used to come out being very
against these terrorists a domino effect
Jill Schlesinger thanks Jill as always